[Musique]
car de bonnes clientes à ça c'est génial
grâce à monica vous reconnais que quand
vous voulez avant même si vous n'êtes
pas de film avant de vous passer finira
comme ça comme ça quand vous les 6,1
soit vous savez pas quoi faire
non mais c'est vrai que vous êtes dans
ce film complètement normal qu avec des
jeans des baskets les cheveux coupés
courts pas très bien coupé en plus on
sait c'est vraiment difficile pour vous
de faire ça non c'est pas difficile à
c'était justement intéressant d'échanger
des personnages parce que c'est vrai que
moi même si je fais des robes de rôle le
fort on partait toujours du fait que les
personnages mais un certain physique et
là c'est complètement différent je vais
pas sur la séduction enfin moins que
d'habitude disons beaucoup moins que
d'habitude c'est pas les chars
laissez-passer duction je sais c'est une
femme avec un physique banal mais qui a
un qui a une démarche alors les lois du
fantasme à la quand même vous êtes la
manière détournée documentariste et un
chirurgien c'est scalpel
tout est très essentiel du coup même les
jeux qu'ils veulent et ses actes or
c'est justement sur la retenue
une certaine pudeur même dans les jeux
et je crois que malgré ça quand même si
nous ne pensions pas tout à fait alors
voilà donc c'est votre huitième film
avec vincent cassel
c'est le premier où il se passe rien
entre vous vous êtes un faux couple pour
devrait donc il ya quelque chose mais
voilà il n'ya pas deux il ya pas de
conclusions et vous dites souvent quand
on vous pose la question mais travailler
avec vincent ça nous permet de nous voir
davantage voilà donc c'est vous joignez
l'utile à l'agréable
il est où là il est au brésil
il a paris c'est paris non mais c'est
vrai que nous on voyage énormément où on
travaille pas tous ensemble et de séries
voir sur les plateaux c'est super c'est
parce que moi quand je dis toujours en
facilement jeunes acteurs quand je joue
avec lui je ne fais pas la personne que
je connais dans la vie et du court je
dois être à l'auteur ah oui si vous y
tenez l'un l'autre quand vous êtes
important de sa surprise et je crois
c'est important de se surprendre à la
vida les travail je crois c'est le
secret des tours de l'amitié de la moi
c'est plus pour se surprendre que pour
sociaux de vie et finalement non c'est
surveillé je crois que c'est quelque
chose d'horrible vous croyez pas toi tu
sais où il est quand il tourne avec toi
la tête ailleurs voilà
non c'est vrai monique et assuré qu'il
est souvent au brésil vous vous êtes
basé à londres
ce soir il s'est passé pas toujours
facile vous avez de longue séparation on
s'est connus ont été déjà des acteurs et
voilà elle ne tenait qu'à continuer
comme ça et même pire parce que c'est
vrai que on travaille de plus en plus je
suis content c'est l'avis des acteurs et
je crois tu pas qu'il ya une logique
pour que une couple marche
il n'y a pas une loi et moi je pense
toujours que chaque jour en plus qui
fait suite à l'histoire continue est
toujours à nérac ne fait pas des grands
plans sur la comète vide chaque jour est
un jour de gagné finalement pesé très
réaliste mais oui parce que on ne peut
pas les filets pour les autres ont
changé on évolue alors nous aider pas de
nom de séparation puisqu'une fois vous
êtes séparés 5 en tant que tel et des
séparations un an suite qu'on est
vicieux
non mais c'est vrai une fois vous êtes
séparés pendant cinq mois signale le
malheur des autres
sauf deux petites de petite interruption
mais ça bien sûr vous connaissez
non mais cinq mois cinq mois c'est long
quand maintenant c'est long mais en fait
il m'a quand même deux fois pour combien
les jours un million c'est pas ça
maintenant c'est des courtes des taux
courts retrouvailles vous savez vous
savez bien oui mais c'est pas là ce
n'est pas tout les années comme ça ça
l'essence qu'il a dû amener on sait
quand ça s'est passé mais ça veut dire
que ça marche quand vous donnez moi ma
femme n'habite pas avec moi et ça marche
de ses 20 ans elle habite on aura alors
vous êtes jalouses non un petit alien
si vous trompez ce que vous tuez par
exemple voilà une question à oui je
pourrais vous ça y'est pourriez le tuer
j'aime les femmes qui sont capables de
tuer il n'y a plus y en a plus je n'ai
pas peur qui tombe amoureux d'une
partenaire dans ce jeu parler c'est
normal mais se trouvait avec de très
belles femmes sur les plateaux même
dehors du plateau
je crois que ça fait partie du jury ce
nom vous dit vous êtes acteur tous les
deux
donc il peut se retrouver nu mais
tendance qui se retrouve nue dans un
film est ce que vous lui interdirait ou
est ce que vous le trouvez ça bien vous
réagiriez comment je le vois dans son
film nu je garde c'est pas de vent non
non j'ai réussi bon ben ça veut dire
qu'il a très bien joué
voilà il est dans son personnage qui
finira pas dans un premier temps
quand vous êtes avec lui comme ça comme
ça un très bon comédien
vous voyez quand il vous parle s'ils
jouent la comédie ou si j'étais toi que
mon sens un comédien qui a énormément de
talent vous allez sans ce que veut il
peut tout faire
c'est vrai que il fait un énorme
sexuelle dans in the baisse et les super
il fait une homme de la rue dans sur mes
lèvres et une y croire on fait
l'aristocrate dans le pack de nous
l'agent secret on y croit je devrais pas
dire ça mais mais mais là je crois si
j'y suis tout à fait mais il a de la
chance ce vincent cassel parce que vous
êtes une telle star une telle icône que
je suis sûr que les mecs au spa vous
draguer je suis sûr que vous leur fait
peur aux mecs
non non je pars non non je crois pas non
je suis
c'est pas du tout d'argent heureuse je
suis assez douces dfc intouchable à
laquelle on nous que demander des
autographes
non je suis pas l'image que je projette
je crois que je ne crois pas qu'on sait
ce qu'on projette moi j'ai fait mon
métier souvent que peut-être que l'image
glacée des photos des couvertures peut
donner une image qui peut être plus
froid devait mais moi je ne crois pas
les trucs froides à l'asie alors vous
aimez en fait être une vraie femme vous
et c'est ça que je trouve remarquable
parce que vous le dites est aujourd'hui
souvent les filles les actrices le
disent pas vite à quoi bon mettre des
belles robes avec des tas de boutons
derrière s'il n'y a pas une main virile
pour les déboutonnée là vraiment je
mérite un bon tandem c'est une attitude
en canoë à c'est un jour elle vous a
données unitaires du canoë
vous êtes jamais dit ça je trouve ça pas
mal pourtant il a couvert journée
d'ailleurs c'est pas mal mais c'est le
jury ce qu'il a dit par mois ah bon mais
d'ailleurs il a raison pas parce que
vous dites aussi dans la série j'aime
être une femme et que les sommes soient
des hommes c'est leur sauvagerie
oh la la maintenant je l'aï c'est donc
c'est la sauvagerie leur bestialité leur
brutalité qui fait que nous sommes
attirés par là moi je sais pas ce qu'il
arrive c'est une fille que j'aimais bien
ce que tu as envie de faire des si vous
dites d'ailleurs je crois qu'elle
arrivait quelque chose mais alors est ce
que pour vous quand même ça je voulais
bien dit un moment est ce que pour vous
là la peur de l'acte sexuel ne va pas de
pair avec l'érotisme
oui vous vous êtes fascinés par le
tableau de picasso la dora maar quand
même bien aimé le temps c'est vrai
mais c'est pas mal d'être une vraie
femme moi je trouve
oui mais savait pas dire que l'on aime
un homme qui est brutal ou qui est macho
moi je n'aime pas ça avant mais quand
même énorme qu'il soit en tout qui
respecte les femmes
[Musique]
en tous les cas vous êtes vous êtes une
vraie ne devrait pas mais ne vous est
pas une italienne d'opérette
puisque vous êtes bien thomas may et
voilà pas content de tonnes c'est
incroyable incroyable vous savez plus
que moi s'est il étonné je sais même le
sexe de l'enfant mais je ne dirais pas
là on a décidé avec votre public vous
paierez surprise c'est pas mon moteur
voilà voilà une chanson j'ai une chanson
pop
[Musique]
mais les battait
et laurent est bon aux bisous
bien alors on va parler d'un autre film
qui sort aussi rapidement là c'est le
film de mel gibson qui s'appelle la la
passion du christ sur les écrans
français le 31 mars
vous jouez le rôle de marie madeleine
pour vous c'est un personnage
extraordinaire parce que vous dites que
marie-madeleine finalement le seul qui
la regarde comme un être humain c'est
jésus et c'est ça qui vous a attiré dans
le personnage ce qui m'attire et ce
justement l'effet que c'est une femme
aux faibles comme mais comme
électriquement
du coup c'est une femme qui pêche comme
moi comme vous je croise on dit comme
tout le monde
et du coup elle ne rappelle l'état une
autre c'est pour ça que j'étais touché
par ce personnage si personnage j'avais
envie de l'incarner à l'écran et voilà
quand je rencontrais ma gibson
on se trouve et voilà et je me suis
retrouvé dans dans ce film c'était une
belle expérience jeter
aaron j'étais amateur sud et l'italie et
c'est vrai que c'est un film rue très
violent mais j'hésite à côté
irréversible ces bandits alors que vous
savez tout c'est vrai je dis ça c'est
vrai je crois que c'est un film très
violent mais comme je dis toujours je
crois que la vie de jésus est violente
et du coup les films ne pouvait pas être
différent vous allez faire la promotion
de ce film j'ai fait je suis pas les
états unis parce que justement que vous
savez j'attendais des et du coup je
voulais pas je sais plus longtemps c'est
le deuxième le savoir j'ai fait là pour
membres agence est clair alors pour vous
faire le film la passion du christ
devait refuser un gros film américain
vouliez vraiment faire le rôle mais ça
l'est les films de ma gibson est
vraiment comme un petit film un petit
badge est jeune indépendant pour moi
c'était un film d'auteur 2010
dès ma gibson ou année sept personnes
croyaient ce film quelque part et nous
allons analyser les cas il faut pas les
faire croot vraiment seul film je sais
que va créer de polémique mais je ne
crois pas que les films dont on voit les
gens me voient le film n y fit tout ce
qui arrive aux as et cécile mais
vraiment personne n'y croyait alors pour
vous en faites la violence cas dans ce
film c'est la violence inhérente à
l'être humain et vous dites quand vous
avez vu le pianiste de polanski
j'ai eu honte de faire partie du genre
humain donc en fait ce film la passion
du christ ne fait que traduire cette
violence qui nous appartient à tous moi
je crois que quand on sort du film
justement ce qu'on sent ce qu'est ce
qu'il ya qui va pas avec l'être humain
pourquoi l'homme des plus des mines en a
pas changé pourquoi l'homme c'est
comporte comme ça avec l'homme et voilà
après bien sûr moi je suis pas quelqu'un
de croyante
comme je dis toujours je suis agnostique
du coup je veux pas parler des choses
que je peux pas expliquer je dis pas je
suis athée parce qu'elle ait raté ceux
déjà prendre une position
je crois qu'elle est trop limité pour
dire à dieu n'existe pas alors vous
dites la technologie c'est ok il ya la
télévision partout il ya le portable
mais en fait l'être humain n'a pas
beaucoup évolué depuis l'homme de
néandertal je crois pas je crois que
peut-être qu'il y à quelque chose
à nous on a quand même des becs
peut-être qu'on fait partie justement de
la nature et la nature je crois qui déjà
à nesle pour avoir un équilibre
elle est fondée sur la violence là
l'essence qui pour exister un loup doit
manger un agneau un lion de mangin
gazelles du coup déjà la nature en soi
et les pas juste les nous on fait partie
de cette nature du coup on a cette
violence à nous c'est pour ça aussi que
moi j'aime bien regarder ce qu'il ya
derrière la façade ce qu'il ya derrière
la marque qu'on a nous pour nous
protéger c'est pour ça que j'ai envie de
faire des signes comme agents seraient
créés par exemple au défilement je dois
chercher les côtés noire des lettres
immenses de l'agent secret vous n'êtes
pas dans vos dans vos repères habituels
je crois que les faits ce qui se passe
ce qui en vieillissant on mûrit et
peut-être moi je sens quand on attire
plus de sécurité du coup sûr moi on me
propose de rôles comment protéger pas
avant et c'est vrai que je dois dire
qu'il compterait que chandler forme a
proposé son film j'étais très flatté
qu'ils avaient pensé à moi pour un rôle
commencé voilà c'est un rôle habituel ça
vous est venu comment c'est pas moi qui
ai eu l'idée c'est le producteur névés
oui voilà et tout de suite éric m'a
parlé de monica qui connaissait pas ce
qu'il avait produit le doberman six ou
sept ans avant j'ai rencontré dans un
petit café à côté de chez elle et je
veux dire qu en dix minutes un quart
d'heure je dirais en dix minutes un
quart d'heure j'ai été assez comment
dire assez fasciné par l'actrice quoi et
le côté prêt prêt à tout pour jouer
c'est à dire à leurs côtés non mais le
côté très une actrice qui peut aller
dans toutes les directions
c'est à dire un moment donné je lui
proposer un rôle peut-être un chemin peu
empruntés et ça l'a tout de suite
beaucoup beaucoup intéressé et je vais
donner le scénario trois jours après
elle m'a appelé en me disant qu'elle
faisait le film et je peux vous dire que
pour un mois je suis un jeune
réalisateur c'est mon deuxième film et
quand vous avez un coup de fil de monica
bellucci qui vous dit qu'elle va faire
le film c'est énorme qu'est ce qui se
passe est de plus en plus vous êtes sûr
de faire le film donc je lui serai
toujours éternel éternellement
reconnaissants non mais c'est vrai je le
dis voilà
monica vous préférez les mecs beau gosse
les mecs intelligents les mecs comme moi
bah alors que vous êtes intelligent et
beau gosse comme vous alors on a plus
vous êtes habillé maintenant pour moi
pour vous l'unission brook j'ai
l'habitude chamblanc oui alors qu'elle
est qu'elle est la meilleure phrase
monica pour vous abordez pas de me dire
je serai que jusque là facile votre
poème préféré je l'apprends ray parker
moi j'aime bien ah s'il vient ce poème
je connais ça comment elle l'a pas dit
c'est en italien vous allez dire dites
moi alors là parlez-moi italien je vais
fermer les yeux je vais craquer
complètement quelques mois juste
quelques verres s'il vient du même coup
à la cool terme de l'atonie de mortal
qu'elle changeait car ce métier
sébastien alors l'endroit idéal pour
vous donner un premier rendez vous
imaginez que vous donnent rendez vous
puisque bon là on a un petit peu tous
les deux alors un restaurant parce que
j'ai bien mangé d'accord oui c'est vrai
à lyon c'est vrai vous aimez bien manger
c'est ça qui est génial c'est
épicurienne brutal hier j'ai dépassé le
geste qui vous fait craquer chez un
homme
les chais ce qui me fait craquer un peu
les larmes aux yeux un homme qui pleure
vrai nom ça ne l'intéresse pas attiré 1
et la place que j'essaye de un geste je
parle ça peut être par une caresse
mais même car est-ce qu'on se ferait à
soi ça peut te va craquer le geste qui
trahi votre trouble à gg devient rouge
je vous dis je des plaques partout voilà
ben ali dont je garde quand vous êtes
comme ça c'est que vous êtes troublé par
l'homme qui est en face côté où elle a
des sentiments à la la qu'est l'alcool
qui vous montre le plus rapidement à la
tête à tout parce qu'un essai j'ai je
bois pas trop et les mains donc à lui
être qu'elle est la ville la plus
romantique selon vous monica par des
roms comme paris rome et paris le
quartier où on a le plus de chance de
vous rencontrer
la rapport à l'aéroport bien le
compliment qu'il ne faut jamais vous
faire j'aime tous les compliments sont
jamais at elle conclu celui qu'on vous a
jamais fait
je crois que dans la montée on est
impressionné par les gens qui savent rod
et qui savent quoi
rod et non cotées ça veut dire faire un
retour tout comme les bébés et c'est
après procès
mes enfants sont de faire un homme qui
se fait certes ça casserait tout pour
vous ça casse ça casserait tout bon mais
quand on le sait comme heurtera pas
qu'elle ait envie de péter
j'accueille maintenant monica bellucci
et bernard campan
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui mais qui à bellucci et bernard
campan le nouveau couple du cinéma
français mesdames messieurs bonsoir
vous êtes grandin monica celle des
talons quand même pour une italienne est
assez grande
vous êtes petit bernard alors vous êtes
ici pour combien tu m'aimes
le nouveau film de bertrand blier avec
vous deux gérard depardieu jean pierre
darroussin ça sort mercredi voilà alors
bernard dans le film vous jouez un homme
qui gagne au loto et qui décide
d'épouser une prostituée qui est
interprétée par monica bellucci c'est
bien le cinéma côté c'est mieux que la
vie quand même
voilà voilà que pour moi vos coups de
bol vous est demandé que le tournage
dure plus longtemps vous êtes inquiétés
non non non non non on n'a pas ça n'a
pas fait de ritek que tu veux savoir
on a on est resté à ce qui était écrit
malheureusement mais ça s'est très bien
passé très très bien alors vous monica
après keanu reeves et bruce willis ça
fait quoi de jouer avec un un séducteur
comme acquis pour tati posait comme
bernard campan je suis très flatté
vraiment j'étais gâté d'ailleurs d'avoir
à côté de moi un acteur comme il est
excitant quand même et excitant monica
dans combien tu m'aimes vous jouez donc
le rôle d'une prostituée
vous dites l étude comme toutes les
femmes qui veulent séduire
c'est vrai la liste en ce que moi je
cherche un mois que j'ai commencé du
triste j'ai utilisé aussi ça et un prêt
et bien sûr à côté de moi j'avais un des
grands maîtres du cinéma français
bertrand blier et ses sorties travailler
à la caractère pareil on apprend
énormément en tant que comédienne de
misogynie quand même nom la polynésie
mais en fait pour moi j'étais pas qu'il
est misogyne et parce qu'il a toujours
écrit drôle et très fort pour les femmes
est un réalisateur qui écrit drôle comme
ça ça veut dire qu'ils aiment les femmes
tout simplement et même les rôles des
maps aussi tué des daniela c'est vrai
c'est bon si tu es même étant c'est une
femme est très forte très libre qui
décident de ce qu'elle veut et les très
très très sauvage c'est ça qui me plaît
du coup ça vaut le femise alors dans ce
film vous n'êtes pas une prostituée en
cuissardes et en skaï avec porte
jarretelles et guêpière vous n'êtes pas
vulgaire du tout vous êtes habillé
classique espèce de prostituées un peu
fellinienne la mama est là et la [ __ ]
mots
alors je dis mama quand même parce que
c'était juste après l'accouchement et
quand même vous êtes bien est incroyable
aujourd'hui j'aurais pu passer à ce rôle
pareil et c'est toute cette chère tout
cette rondeur dans quelque chose des
jeunes heureux personnage quelque part
c'est comme si elle aimait la terre
entière
ce n'est que cet or comme vous avez dit
justement un thé fellinien et je crois
que c'est fini mais ceux-ci nommage au
cinéma italien pendant tournage à
laitiers entre les prises
mais d'ailleurs j'ai trouvé ça très très
beau et tristan pour y remédier à les
dépasser à faire ton vol à voir les
scènes d'amour avec bernard et après
voilà ça fait drôle quand elles disent
un essai noël bernard bernard que ça
doit faire drôle surtout
ça vous a pas gêné monica de montrer
votre corps comme ça alourdit quand même
non
je dois dire que j'ai eu un moment de
peur quand j'ai après tout de suite
après l'accouchement parce que je savais
que trois mois après je devais commencer
à tourner je me disais juste serait
jamais prêt est prêt je dis je ne peux
pas faire autrement je suis comme ça et
je crois que voilà c'est bien aussi
d'avoir le courage de mettre en scène
une femme qui est lé contraire des codes
de la mode d'aujourd'hui
alors il faut être agrandi filiforme et
elle est l'opposé les dessins énorme
dans le film voilà voilà
à la can est un peu d'eau je vais pas
tenir tout l'été ils jouent au 6eme
délais sont aussi et joue un rôle
d'aidant vos mensurations normales c'est
95 60 90 c'est ça va vérifier c'est à
dire que j'aime aussi beaucoup de scènes
d'amour physique tous les deux vous avez
déclaré pour ses scènes soient bien
jouer il faut qu'une vraie relation
entre les deux noms comme et sont jaloux
mais quatre
mais si c'est important c'est du jeu et
c'est bien qu'il y à l'intimité qu'il y
a quand même tu peux pas faire ça il ya
les acteurs avec qui tu joues mais des
acteurs avec tu joues pas bien je dois
dire qu'il bernanke a revu ses
partenaires en magnifique je le crois
pas vraiment gagner au loto à la baisse
vraiment un jour bertrand ma place et
bingo alors vous dites on entre vraiment
dans l'intimité de l'autre quand on joue
ce genre de scène dans les sens que
c'est il faut
et s'ils n'ont pas les scènes d'amour
qui sont difficiles à jouer c'est plutôt
faire croire à l'amour parce que quand
même et si moi c'est à me reprocher
c'est une représentation de la réalité
tout simplement et c'est vrai qu'il
comptait avec quelqu'un avec qui tu
t'entends bien et ça c'était le cas avec
bernard mais c'est vrai que j'étais
entouré de par leur incroyable j'étais
entourée de mecs qui étaient là pour me
sentir bien mais protégé et je crois que
sans les stands attendaient là avec ce
sourire salaire salaire tout le monde
maintenant alors il ya un côté
effectivement très physique et un lien
comme ça l'opéra les pâtes le linge qui
sèche sur le part dieu où le baril
absolument il ya une italianité dans le
film qui fait penser effectivement à
silvana mangano à gina lollobrigida
sophia loren ça c'est trop - qu'est-ce
que j'étais dire c'est que bien sûr
aujourd'hui je finis cinéma c'est parce
que cette femme là ces familles là m'ont
fait rêver bien sûr et je crois que mais
aussi bertrand blier m et cinéma italien
à voile à l'issue auriez pu atteindre
mais je réfléchissais danse éric
bertrand il fonctionne à l'inspiration
quoi et je pense que je sais pas si au
début du film
l'italie allait prendre une place aussi
importante
de même que deux cordes de daniela a
pris beaucoup de place et vitaly aussi
peut-être dans l'inspiration de bertrand
a fait son chemin et des airs d'opéra
ont débarqué le film est devenu franco
italien très bien et très très vite quoi
alors bernard bellucci bertrand blier
c'est bien pour un ex un cône et non oui
vous savez pourquoi vous avez choisi
bertrand blier berlin jeu ça il avait vu
le film de zabou breitman souvenir des
belles choses et j'ai envie de à
l'occasion c'est une idée de voile
inspiré me dit vous avez un côté ou lb
kg 1 c'est à dire un peu français moyen
oui bah voilà monsieur tout le monde
mec lambda ouais ça me samba ça me
convient la quintessence du physique
français alors dans le prochain film de
zabou breitman cessé de charles berling
dont vous tombez amoureux
oui ça va le changer finies les vacances
fait moindrot monica ca va bien très
bien
j'ai pas vu vincent cassel depuis
blueberry donc va le remplacer on va
faire un hit radio
vincent cassel bonsoir vincent cassel ça
me fait très plaisir de vous recevoir
comment allez-vous vous avez laissé
pousser vous je veux bah oui pour un
rôle les 14es pour un jouet je suis
prête à tout les griots sylvain
simplement vous trouvez bola merci je
suis pas [ __ ] mais le bouc est dedans et
de révéler radieux c'est l'amour qui
vous rend comme ça bah oui ça se passe
bien et monica oui vous êtes content
d'avoir un enfant avec elle ici
ferrari ça vous plaît d'être papa
absolument le faire d'autres enfants
avec elles agissent pas qu'est ce que ça
fait quand on entend aurait été toute la
journée que sa femme est la plus belle
femme du monde
ouais qu'est ce que vous aimez chez
monica vincent qu'est ce que la deux
qu'est ce qu'elle a de plus beau selon
vous
vous êtes jaloux oui oui c'est normal
c'est vrai que tu cherches bernard
campan partout pour les bourrer la
gueule qu'est ce qui vous énerve le plus
chez elle il ya déjà un film de monica
coup n'avait pas aimé vincent non damée
dernier film de blier vraiment il est
bien faut dire que c'est un bon blier
adoré vraiment je plonge et des dangers
trouver les films incroyables je crois
que pour la carrière de monica c'est
très bien ça les fait j'ai pensé qu'ils
vraiment je l'avais jamais vu comme ça
vous veillez monica souvent vincent non
pas vraiment parce qu'il tourne à vide
est encore en train je lui étais en
mongolie là était mongolie il allait
rentrer il ya internet ou du coup ils
travaillent là là là et vincent vous
draguez toujours un peu vous quand même
bah oui non magie reste quand même
énorme
ces mêmes et sans il faut regarder les
autres femmes pour apprécier la sienne
vincent sérieusement si elle partait
vous feriez quoi j'ai lavé serez libre
c'est la seule manière pour qu'il
retourne en arrière
guy mallinson vincent geisser il a
changé
il va me parler comme ça ya encore six
mois mais il s'y connait un sexuellement
ça se passe bien avec monica vincent
bien très bien très bien
vous avez fait quoi pour la séduire
vincent
j'étais juste souvent même avant c'est
embêtant pour les autres qu'est-ce que
vous détestiez le plus chez vous vincent
mon côté feuq et ceci ma force
notre principal défaut c'est quoi
vincent et rois et royaumes ça se dit
chez nous mais ça doit sonner est
[Applaudissements]
marrant c'est très marrant qu'il dise ah
ouais parce que moi aussi je me sens un
peu ivres ou en angola quelqu'un qui est
déjà beaucoup d'énergie italien des
ikhwan c'est normal vous avez peur
qu'elle vous tromper les cas on a eu
berlin comptant il est sûr de lui il ya
des choses que vous aimeriez dire à
monica vincent ce soir revient déjà plus
dans tous les cas merci vincent remet
quand vous voulez je trouve super mini
amis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]